do you think um satire and parody are
like are like satanic no I don't think
so because I think they can be used to
highlight truth but I think that what
happens is the world can become so
insane that something which in any other
era would be a harmless joke is now
something taken seriously so here's a
great example there was a bit in Monty
Python's meaning of life where a child
is born and they give it to the mother
and the mother says is it a boy or a
girl and the doctor says well it's a bit
early to be assigning roles to it don't
you think and I remember seeing that 10
years ago and going oh my gosh they made
this joke decades ago and this is
actually about to be a massive social
justice issue quote unquote and it is
now so so I don't think that it was evil
for Monty Python to make that joke I
think the direction that our country has
gone in is evil